as dubba continues to use his skating
ability and strength to pound pucks
bouncing Doo swats at it haves had it for
a moment now Jack Johnson the X king with
a drive stick save and the puck over
the glass and off the right wi boards
a shot wide and then at the other way with
speed lafier lafier a shot in tight turned
aside by gorv cross ice pass hit a body and
abs sticker leg but fiaa gets it back head
scores oh they're going to continue play fala
reacted as if he scored and we said this earlier
this season been talking about less feet more
hands well right here it did go off to Nick it
went off the inside boom all the way across
bang m you can see that gorev's in position
he he was there he saw it but the shot look
at that for the ABS will have a 156 and two
record Kings with numbers dubba for Grom a shot
save is made for fiala and back ahead to Jordan
Spence feeds more more with a shot kicked out
rebound back to Moore Ranon in down low broken
stick out there for the king okay saves across
and a one-time McKinnon save is made Brunton and
a blast Carl lost an edge going for the puck
in the corner and here comes Nathan McKinnon
stick handling feeds it across now they get it
to Manson who scores oh great Puck movement and
Manson finishes the play and the ABS have the
one- nothing lead but it's a second wave we
talked about attacks this is one of the keys
to the game because this is how the Avalanche
basically score most of their goals it's on attack
and look at the one touching there McKinnon gets
the speed to get entry roton gets the one-touch
pass Manson says hey I'm going to be the second
wave maybe a redirection there with speed Kee
into the middle hands it off Kopitar couldn't
get around pum cleanly now he feeds Anderson
with a shot and a stick save pick of dowy
still one- nothing Colorado viala checked trailing
Deno wristed wide Den know chopping it in front
knocked away kept in Roy for Moore and out up
high to gabov he'll shoot save fought off by
gorv kopar Kee in Byfield out against
the big line for Colorado Ronin a shot
from distance gloved by cam talot now a big hit by
grundstrom Buck winds up and on talit he put
it right into the middle of ok Conor and then
a chance for a Colton and Talbot was able to
recover and make a save sometimes you lose s
of the fact that when they want to be Colorado
can be a very good defensive team with their
skating ability and experience lead pass Lewis
are on one man in a chance save gorev look just
keeping pucks alive making it happen this is
what you need to do check for your chances I
know that's way back to the pregame show the
veteran Trevor Lewis look out two onone the
other way Pagano shoots Glo save talin there we go
back and forth stoy was talking about that and the
Kings Auda watch again the calmness of talin now
there he is confident y did a great job standing
his ground holding his position at the top of the
paint and here is Kopitar plays It Off the Wall
in backhander save made oh chances at both ends
continue here early in the second period cheese
here in the second period great one pass beats
everyone nice play because it's off the wall and
the carum watch Gori up again I I think he's fixed
on that puck I hate to see it because Charlie lren
caught my attention in the last game maybe a
little stick into the hands Ronin for McKinnon
McKinnon stopping starting threw it in front TI in
on goal maybe off a king a couple of quick breaks
in this game meaning a couple of quick attacks
both sides getting it but I would consider it
mostly a low event game so far kick save Colton
battles to get it back feeds Manson with a shot
tipped and wide wood may have got a touch on it
o' Conor battling for Colton Colton out to Taves
a shot t side of the net and controlled by tablet
boy over where the puck is there's the caram that
happened in the last game too pad it looked
like it was going in right but it's on the
outside and then it drops in behind McKinnon
dumps it in Ronin around to McKinnon watched
by Anderson stumbles a bit and the puck to Kee
Kee with skating room drops it for the trailer
Anderson score might have been tipped in front
by Quinton Byfield and the Kings have tied it
up Anderson beats McKinnon up the ice and
then with a shot and the redirection it's
there McKinnon thought there should have
been a penalty it's right here Anderson
will swing his stick right there
not much didn't go down but watch
McKinnon he looks behind him look
at that that's all you need that's
all you need and by the he cannot catch
up to Anderson who ends up getting the
shot he'll flip it in he and Byfield will
chase it down loose Puck on the rightwing
boards Kopitar for dowy back to Kopitar moves
in to Kee to bfield score great passing kopar
Kee and Byfield and the Kings have a lead two to
one kee can't get the entry but look at this two
guys on it third man high keep the puck alive
it's just the spread out here watch it oh man
the attack triangle the spacing Kee will push off
go to the outside at the same time we can see the
reaction of Adrien keer after the pass they got
something going here oh the o cross arms fi and
another milestone for Kopitar we'll tell you
about that in a moment he's had a lot of them
here now more spinning shooting and he scores
short side Trevor Moore forever more 3-1 La he
had to make it quick and he decides right now
once he gets it spin he's going there man just
as his hands get in front of the red line he
releases there's no waste of time there's no
hesitation it's skill it's power oh my off the
side of the nogget 235 left 3 to one La the net
is empty and here's Anderson for Byfield for the
hattrick the shot bounces just wide by about 3
in initially like could have a chance has a
chance has a chance but it just hit enough
just enough to go on the side again with a
two-goal lead although analytics tells you
nowadays and that's why teams pull their go
good communication there between dowy and his
teammates he was on his forehand McKinnon shoots
it in dowy up with it long shot at the empty Net
score a 89.4 foot goal for TR shy out quickly
and then Drew says I'm just going to back off
Bingo yeah see that little cow's going
to get an assist here and you think oh
no that that was an important play
they've just taken care of their own
business they're not worrying about who
or when or how or what the NHL does with
the schedule they're not worried about
all that stuff they just winning games